[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Cloud
Dataproc is a fast, easy to use,
fully managed cloud service for
running Apache Spark and Apache
Hadoop clusters in a simpler,
more cost-efficient way.
Operations that used to
take hours or even days
now take seconds
or minutes instead.
Create Cloud Dataproc clusters
quickly and resize them
at any time, so you don't
have to worry about your data
pipelines outgrowing
your clusters.
Dataproc doesn't
just provide you
with a Spark or Hadoop cluster.
With built-in integrations
to other GCP services,
you have a powerful
and complete platform
for data processing, analytics,
and machine learning.
This Qwik Start shows you
how to use the Google Cloud
Platform to create a Google
Cloud Dataproc cluster,
run a simple Apache
Spark job in the cluster,
then modify the number of
workers in the cluster.
This lab is part of the
baseline Data, ML, and AI
quest on Qwiklabs Completing
all of the labs in this quest
earns you this badge to
recognize your new skills.
You can show off your badge
on your resume or social media
channels.
Next on our quest--
Dataprep Qwik Start.
Although you don't need
your own GCP account
to work on these labs, if
you're ready to get started,
use the link below to
receive a $300 GCP credit.